- I'M GONNA CLEAR IT.
- GET 'EM.
- NOPE.
THAT DIDN'T--
THAT DIDN'T WORK AT ALL.
OW. OW.
- A LITTLE BIT.
HEY, IF YOU GUYS SEE ANYTHING
NINJA-RELATED, TELL ME,
'CAUSE I AM BACK ON MY
NINJA KICK.
- OKAY.
- I'M GONNA GET A SHOWER RADIO,
SO I CAN LITERALLY
ROG OUT WITH MY COG OUT.
- OR WE COULD JUST STICK
TO THE CAMPING LIST,
GET THE SUPPLIES WE NEED,
RIGHT?
- DEFINITELY,
BUT FIRST, I WANT TO GET
THE STUFF THAT I WANT
TO GET FIRST.
- YEAH.
- KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
- I'M GONNA DO THAT TOO.
- ALL RIGHT, JUST--
YOU KNOW, TRAVEL SHAMPOOS.
LOOK FOR 'EM.
COME ON, 35 BUCKS?
FOR WHAT?
OH, PLUGS INTO THE CAR.
THAT'S COOL.
- GOING CAMPING THERE,
PAUL BUNYAN?
- UH, NO,
ME AND MY BUDDIES ARE
GONNA FOLLOW
A CONCERT TOUR,
SO WE'RE JUST GONNA,
LIKE, BE CAMPING OUT.
- THAT SOUNDS FUN.
- YEAH, IT SHOULD BE.
I'M NOT REALLY
A GREAT OUTDOORS GUY, THOUGH.
YOU KNOW, UNLESS THERE'S
A BALD-HEADED BEAR.
- YEAH.
- FROM THE MOVIE, UM--
- WHAT MOVIE'S THAT?
- IT'S THE GREAT OUTDOORS.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- SHH.
- I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD--
ARE YOU PREGNANT?
- SHH, SHH, SHH, SHH, SHH.
IT'S NOT FOR YOU TO KNOW
WHAT'S INSIDE THIS BELLY.
- YOU'RE SQUEEZING SO HARD.
- YOU LIKE THAT?
- I LIKE IT.
- OH, LOOK AT THAT.
SOMEONE'S UP.
- OH, YEAH.
- SOMEONE'S UP.
- I'M UP.
- MORNING.
- I'M UP AND AT 'EM.
- DON'T DO THAT WITH YOUR FACE.
DON'T DO THAT.
I DON'T LIKE THAT.
THAT'S BETTER.
- OH, GOD, ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
- [squeals]
- [groaning]
[camera shutter clicks]
- AHA.
- WAIT, DID YOU JUST TAKE
A PICTURE OF ME?
- [laughs] THANK YOU.
- WHO ARE YOU?
DON'T--
- YOU NEED SOME HELP THERE,
MY FRIEND?
- WHAT?
UH, UM, NO.
NO.
I'M, UH--I'M ALL RIGHT.
I'M JUST GETTING SOME PANTS.
- HOW ABOUT A LARGER SIZE?
- NO, I-I THINK THEY'RE GOOD.
[clears throat] SO.
WEAR 'EM OUT.
[laughs quietly]
GOOD DAY.